there's no losing your bank card when
you're a customer of spain's kaiser bank
it's the first in europe to introduce
this
a wristband that lets you make purchases
of up to 20 euros a chip in the
waterproof band works exactly like the
chip in your credit or debit card and
contains all your encrypted data
after a successful trial over the summer
they'll now be available to thousands of
customers
this is just the latest in a long line
of cashless payment methods
near field communication or nfc has been
used in smartphones since 2011
but when apple got in on the act last
month launching apple pay
it was a sign that this tech had hit the
big time
it's not been without its problems
though some major retailers in the us
have turned their nfc readers off while
they wait for their own technology to
come online
so companies are not only competing for
your money
they're competing for the technology you
use to spend it